we're just reaching the end of our july
4th weekend here so it's time for my
july updates where i'm going to talk
about
what i did or what happened during the
month of june
and about what we've got coming up in
july there's there's a lot of
interesting things both that happened
and that are coming up
i also took some down time some of it
scheduled vacation time some of it uh
due to getting sick i'll talk about that
in a few moments but first i want to
fill you in on a few of the really
the most important things at least as
far as i'm concerned the things that are
kind of extending the range of what it
is that i'm doing so in june i signed up
with google they'd invited me
to become a provider
on what they call help outs and with
helpouts you you schedule some time with
an expert or a practitioner or you know
some sort of coach
in in some sort of skill set in my case
it has to do with with philosophy of
course and how to apply it how to study
it how to
make progress in the field and
you get a one-on-one interaction with
them through google hangouts
so this this offers me the capacity
to really work from from just about
anywhere that has a reliable internet
connection
and do one-on-one
work with with people who want to
study philosophy
figure out how to apply it within their
own life
set up a program all those sorts of
things so
i've put a link to that below and i
might talk about that a little bit more
later on in this video
um
what else happened in june i continued
with my marist online ethics class i
have about 31 students in the class
and they're very actively engaged which
is good
a lot of forum discussions they seem to
be learning the material quite well
which i'm happy to see
i did a little bit more work on my
plairno
existentialism class which is still not
entirely
ready for prime time i'm you know i'm
kind of babying this a bit perhaps a bit
more than i ought to but i want it to be
i want to have all the things in place
before i release it
um and then i i took a vacation we uh we
went out to the beach in montauk for
about a week which was very relaxing
and uh really enjoyable my my wife and
kids we all had some good down time
together had some some good seafood just
being in the the beach environment and
walking along the ocean and you know the
the ocean air is
wonderful
sort of a rejuvenation
then we got back here and then i
came down with limes
for the second time
uh in in my life
and unfortunately i started getting the
the the rash on my leg
and you know usually limes looks like a
big bull's eye and it didn't look like a
bull's-eye but my wife was getting kind
of concerned so i went to the emergency
room and they looked at it and they said
no no it's not limes it's actually mrsa
so they misdiagnosed it and they gave me
the wrong antibiotic for it and after
about three days it wasn't getting any
better and i did start seeing the big
bullseye
and i said yeah
i better get this checked out so i
called my my doctor
and they said yeah come in
on
the weekend you know on a friday just
before
they closed and
the doctor looked at it and said dad
definitely lyme disease we've got to put
you on the antibiotic for that
and that has been um kind of
debilitating because
unlike many of the infections that you
can get where they give you an
antibiotic it might make you feel sick
you know
screw up your your intestines a little
bit doxycycline makes you feel nauseous
a lot of the time makes you really tired
run down and i had this before so i knew
what to expect and i knew i wasn't going
to get quite as much work done as i had
hoped
so that's you know that's still going on
i'm still going through the course of
treatment i have a couple more uh weeks
i think to take the pills
but i did do some things i had a talk
recently at the library as part of the
glimpses of existence
series uh this one was on lab shestoff a
very important but underrated
existentialist philosopher a russian
jewish guy who
had to leave russia shortly after the
the the communists took over the
bolsheviks and went to paris and then
was
very influential in the paris scene you
know influenced people like georges
bataille
um
new husserl
um camus mentions him although
disparagingly in the mythos and there
were a lot of other people who were
affected by him
um
i did a few punk rock philosophers show
segments
supplying some some clips where we were
talking about different philosophical
topics primarily hegel
and i did some videos or rather
released videos that i'd shot beforehand
because i knew that during the vacation
time i was going to want to have some
material ready so some of them were core
concept videos mostly on wd ross's
intuitionist moral theory coming from
his his book the right and the good and
those i was actually shooting for my
marist ethics students because i wanted
them to have these little you know
sound almost sound bite you know
videos that they could use as they're
working their way through this material
i did a few half-hour hegel
uh videos not as not as much as i would
have liked but you know illness kind of
kind of prevented that and i did do one
video and i was surprised how popular
it's it's become
on ten philosophical works that i would
bring to a desert island so i think i
may do some more
uh of those sort of five or ten
works or ideas or things like that down
the line
um i'm not i'm not exactly sure when or
or what ones i'm going to do but but you
know i'll talk a bit more about that i
spent a good portion of the time
actually
re-reading large parts of jacques
lacan's corpus because i'm working on a
book chapter
for a book that is going to be on ethics
of subjectivity
and
i'm doing the chapter on jacques laca
somebody who i've had a long standing
interest in haven't written that much
about just one article
back in the
mid 2000s on the mirror stage but
somebody who i have been meaning to do
some academic writing on for quite some
time in part because i actually was in a
erasmus institute summer seminar for
faculty members led by aleister mcintyre
back in 2005 and it was centered on
it was called
practical rationality
rational choice theory
thomas aquinas jacques lacan and
when i saw that that
title and the call for participants i
said well is exactly what i what i want
to do because i'm really interested in
the the aristotelian thomas tradition
i knew the rational choice theory stuff
that they wanted to talk about and its
roots in hobbs and hume and i've had a
long-standing interest in freud and
lacan and you know
in my past incarnation as a philosopher
i was actually somebody who was doing
continental philosophy and i i left
quite a few of those guys behind because
i i felt that
what they were doing while it was very
interesting was
rather abstruse and limited
and i know that a lot of people when i
say this are going to say wait a second
is really dense and impenetrab
impenetrable to read but i actually find
a lot of the things that he has to say
uh very very insightful so
it was it was a lot of fun to to reread
this material and do some writing on it
i haven't finished the article but i'll
be finishing it this month and i also
submitted a textbook proposal
uh early on in june
for
a press and academic press that wanted
me to to propose a book
for today's students looking at
you know contemporary issues
that they face not just you know like
capital punishment or global hunger
those are important things but you know
what about dating
you know what about the ethics of that
and the proposal was that i should write
about that
and try to show how ancient philosophy
and their conceptions of the good life
could inform them you know does
aristotle actually have anything to say
to today's undergraduate students and my
answer is yes because i've been teaching
aristotle in in ethics classes for you
know over 10 years
and
the examples that i i've used in class
and the conversations that i've had have
been a lot of moments where students
would be like wow this really puts
things into context so so i submitted a
textbook proposal on that we'll see if
they pat if they if they go for it if
they don't then i'll just submit it to
another place because it's a book that
needs to be written
so that's what happened in june
july we're already like a weekend
july i'm going to be doing a lot of help
outs hopefully it's it's up to people
whether they actually um
sign on for them the first one the way
i'm doing it right now the first one is
free and then after that it costs
i'm continuing my ethics class of course
and i'm finishing up that plairno class
but something else that i'm doing this
this coming weekend is
pretty important for me and may end up
playing a big role
in the work that i'm going to be doing
in the future
i'm getting certified with the appa
in philosophical counseling and there
there's several different bodies out
there that certify philosophical
councils you might say what's a
philosophical counselor
it's somebody who
makes philosophy practical which is what
i do you know reason io's motto is
philosophy into practice so this is
right up my alley and it's the sort of
work that i've actually been doing
in an unofficial way
with
people for well really the last 10 years
where i take philosophical
concepts and texts and approaches and
say
yeah this is how this would play out in
your life you've got this this problem
or this recurring issue
or this this you know relationship that
seems to be going sour or this whole
string of relationships that seem to
keep going sour for the same reason or a
general malaise or i'm not sure what i
should do with my life those are the
sorts of things that that classically
it wasn't just you know psychologists
who dealt with or life coaches or you
know pick whatever
thing you like along those lines
that's what philosophy was for you know
aristotle that's what he was about not
just that of course he did his natural
science too but that was part of what he
was interested in plato you know the
care of the soul
um
that was that was you know central to
his ideas epictetus you know we could go
down the list
philosophy
and this is part of what kept me
interested in it all the way down to the
existentialists was not just about
abstract problems or you know
one upsmanship in terms of argument it
was about how to figure out what to do
with your screwed up life
and
all of our lives are screwed up too by
the way including the philosophers but
it's a question of getting further along
so you know doing this this uh actual
certification process in philosophical
counseling i'm hoping i'm going to learn
some some new frameworks and some new
concepts and get introduced to some
people that have been themselves doing
this kind of work for a while i'm not
exactly sure what to expect from it but
you know the readings that they've given
us are really interesting so i'm looking
forward to having a great
time
it's a very intense
course of studies but but it's it's
fortunately
fairly short although the reading that
we've been doing is you know going on
for a while
uh what else i'm going to be giving
another talk in this library series i'm
not doing a lot of talks this month but
i will be giving another glimpses of
existence talk
this one will be on on kafka
and i'll talk mostly about i think the
trial
and the castle
and a few of the stories including the
metamorphosis the judgment
and
the prison colony
maybe a few others as as well i mean
that's a lot of stuff to pack into an
hour and a half talk but
should be fun i've got some videos
coming up as well uh i haven't gotten
around to doing some of the 10 shorts
and some questions have been
accumulating so i needed to do a few of
those
i've got a lot of aristotle core concept
videos coming up this month primarily
oriented on
nickel mccain ethics book five and the
question of justice the different types
of justice
and one question can one do injustice to
oneself
i've got some half-hour hegel videos i'm
going to try to do them more or less
weekly over this month
and
depending on what happens with the
philosophical counseling training and
certification
i might do a video about that talking
about
what's involved what it was like for me
i don't know i have to see what what
happens with that that's kind of a black
box
at this time but
by next weekend it won't be
so
a lot of fun stuff coming up
um
getting ready for the fall when we're
going to be rolling out
uh some new youtube channels we're going
to continue
with this channel doing the half hour
hegel doing the existentialism videos
doing um
some talks here and there that they
allow me to record and doing core
concept videos
but we're also going to be rolling out
this september
the very first of the new channels which
will be focused on critical thinking
specifically on critical thinking
might be some higher production videos
and
then we've got some other channels
coming up as well we're going to do one
for ethics we're going to do one for
history of philosophy we're going to
probably do one for philosophy of
religion
but we're going to be doing it in a kind
of staggered form
and that way people who are interested
in one particular area or want to use
the videos for
say a class
or
you know for training purposes we'll be
able to do that so that's what we've got
coming up in july
been kind of a big month i'm still a
little bit slow be because of the limes
and the
antibiotic that they've got me on so i'm
pretty low energy right now
but um i'm really excited about what
we've got going on